[Musique]
près de 300 manifestants s'étaient donné
rendez vous au jardin de l'état pour
cette première journée sans alcool à
l'initiative de l'association les
maillons de l'espoir et de la fédération
régionale d'addictologie de la réunion
ce rassemblement vise à sensibiliser la
population aux dangers liés à la
consommation d'alcool
vous savez à la réunion toutes les
familles mais également une marche
blanche composée d'élus d'acteurs
associatifs et de militants a quitté le
jardin de l'état pour rejoindre la
préfecture
l'alcool un problème de santé publique à
la réunion
450 personnes décèdent chaque année
suite à une consommation excessive
d'alcool soit près d'un décès sur 10
l'alcool ce sont des accidents de la
circulation
c'était violences intrafamiliales arrête
avec ça
seppois cela mais à quoi tout mon
soutien aux organisateurs et je veux
qu'il y ait une prise de conscience chez
les réunionnaises et les réunionnais que
l'alcool fait trop de dégâts même mère à
l'enfant des pannes et parfois il est
déjà atteint ce n'est pas admissible
les élus ont ensuite pu remettre une
motion à la préfecture une motion
portant notamment sur la publicité et
l'exonération des taxes sur la vente de
spiritueux locaux et s'est notamment de
pouvoir revoir la fiscalité spécifique
dérogatoires existent dans département
et dans les dom qui permet que soient
commercialisés à très bas prix d alcool
issu de la canne à sucre
cela permet aujourd'hui d'avoir à la
réunion le prix de l'alcool le moins
cher de france ce qui est une aberration
santé publique alors que nous assurent
la deuxième région la plus concernée par
la mortalité liée à l'alcool
[Musique]